wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
wie lange lernen sie schon deutsch
ich lebe seit einigen jahren durch seit
einem jahr
richtig ich weiß dass man das so sagt
aber sprechen sie auch andere sprachen
ich finde ich ja sage ich mit einem
wenig sie sprechen armenisch meine
mutter ist zweisprachig aufgewachsen
auch das ist bei uns normal sprechen sie
auch englisch ich habe schon kurzen
besuch der serie aber leider spreche ich
nicht so gut englisch
ich weiß aber dass im gleichen wichtige
sprache ist welche sprachen lernt ihr
denn in der schule bei uns lernt man
englisch und französisch in der schule
du sprichst französisch leider sprechen
ein bisschen französisch aber ich kann
ganz gut englisch sprechen
verstehe ich bin mir sicher dass du die
b2 sprachprüfung besteht ist echt echt
ich möchte auf jeden fall studieren ich
finde auch dass zu studieren solltest du
schaffst das
für welches studienfach interessierst du
dich ich weiß nicht vielleicht studiere
ich medizin oder ich werde lehrerin wie
du ja du hast ja noch ein bisschen zeit
wir sehen uns morgen ja danke gesagt für
deine hilfe
das mache ich doch gerne